[Music]
so to start these milk buns you want to
make a tang zong so that's the starter
which you're going to end up chilling in
the fridge for an hour it's really easy
to make it comes together really easily
and that's going to help give the milk
fence this really incredible soft
luscious flavor so once your starter's
cool you're going to start making the
dough
the dough is really easy to make but i
think the crucial point about this is
that it's really sticky and that you
need to knead it for like 20 minutes i
know it sounds like a long time and it's
going to seem like it's not coming
together but if you keep kneading it
it'll gradually form a ball that you can
work with
so when you're making bread you always
want to use a starter in this case we're
making a tang zong which is a really
easy starter to make it just has bread
flour whole milk and water other
starters might have yeast but we're
going to add that later in the process
kneading the dough for a long time is
going to help produce the gluten which
is going to make a really airy fluffy
bread i played around with a few recipes
when i was developing this and when i
first made it i was like do you really
need to need it for this long
and you really do in order to get that
fluffiness you really need to take your
time with the dough after you've kneaded
the dough you're gonna let it rise for
an hour hour and a half that's a really
basic step in bread baking after the
dough has risen it's time to divide it
into individual portions so once you
divide the dough up you can flatten a
piece out so that it's like yay big and
then add your filling of choice i added
pulled pork just because i love it but
you could add any filling you want at
that point you're gonna pinch
each side up to slowly seal it
then flip it over so that the seal is on
the bottom and that the smooth side is
on the top
so for thanksgiving i actually had milk
buns rather than dinner rolls and
everyone lost their minds they're like
the best thing ever put the formed buns
back in the baking pan of course you
want really beautiful glossy buns so
brush them with an egg wash and then
you're going to bake it you could also
add toppings like seeds you could use
like an everything bagel spice you can
really get creative here i like to add
sesame seeds i think it just adds a
little bit of extra flavor it's really
aesthetically freezing
um you could even add flaky sea salt
really whatever you want you only need
to bake it for 25-30 minutes until
they're nice and golden brown at this
point you're done just let them cool pop
them out and go crazy i love getting
milk buns when i go out to eat and this
was actually the first time i'd have
ever made the recipe
it was really really fun to make i think
the joy of this is that you can stuff it
like i did with purple pork or you can
put in other ingredients other types of
meat vegetables or you can just have
buns by themselves i think milk buns are
so good because they're so fluffy it's
truly like the fluffiest bread you can
get so you can make this recipe for a
dinner party if you just wanted plain
buns on the side you could make it for a
picnic you could bring it to the beach i
mean these are
great for a barbecue there's so many
options
today i'm going to show you how to make
my sheet pan barbecue chicken cornbread
sandwiches it's a mouthful but it's
really good
cornbread and barbecue are such a
classic combination and i thought it
might be cool to just put them together
and also take out some of the stress of
having people having to do it by
themselves with the sandwich you get it
all in one
while i was developing this recipe it
was really important to have cornbread
that could stay in a sheet and not
crumble apart some cornbread can be
really dense and crumbly which has its
moments but for this we needed something
a little more malleable
[Music]
i think for me this is a perfect thing
for summer barbecue a party a long
weekend it's really a crowd pleaser and
it's pretty easy to do
[Music]
you want to make sure to grease the
baking sheets and line them with
parchment paper if you don't line them
with parchment paper you're not going to
be able to peel them off in one sheet
and that kind of defeats the whole
purpose you want to make sure to divide
them evenly between the two sheet pans
if you don't want one thicker and one
thinner again it's a sandwich you want
them even on both sides the cornbread
bakes really quickly it'll be done in
something like 15 minutes
so while the cornbread's baking you can
move on to the next step which is making
your own barbecue sauce i think when
you're making your own barbecue sauce
the joy is that you can control some
elements like if you want it more spicy
you can add more heat if you want it
sweeter you can add more sugar i just
really like the element of control that
you have when you're making your own
barbecue sauce at home a lot of people
use store bought but it's actually
really easy to make your own sauce it'll
come together in a matter of minutes
so in addition to making our own
barbecue sauce we're also going to make
our own coleslaw the base for the
coleslaw is really easy it's basically
mayonnaise mustard vinegar and some
seasoning
[Music]
so for this coleslaw i'm using cabbage
and carrots if you wanted to add
something else you totally could
[Music]
you're going to add the shredded chicken
to the barbecue sauce give it a stir
it's that easy
[Music]
when you're ready to assemble you'll
place the shredded chicken all over the
cornbread top it with coleslaw put the
other cornbread on top of it and then
you can slice it into pieces as big or
small as you want
[Music]
[Music]
you can make them really small and make
them like sliders for a party or you can
make them bigger if you're having like a
family barbecue
[Music]
people love this idea that's kind of
novel of having like a sheet pan
sandwich i think the joy of the sandwich
is having this really saucy chicken this
really flavorful coleslaw and then of
course the cornbread and it's all
together and you can just have it in one
bite truly the best combination i put
chicken inside this sandwich but you
could use pulled pork brisket whatever
your favorite barbecue is let us know in
the comments
today i'm going to show you how to make
my chicken teriyaki crispy rice noodle
bowl
[Music]
i love chicken teriyaki but it can often
feel so heavy to me and i wanted to make
it in a way that felt lighter and a
little more exciting so i think using
the fried noodles incorporating some of
these other really fresh toppings makes
it feel fresh and exciting while still
having that really incredible flavor
from the teriyaki sauce so to start this
recipe you're going to make the teriyaki
sauce it's really simple you're whisking
a few ingredients together and set it
aside
so i used really thin vermicelli noodles
for this so you want to make sure that
you're taking small portions of the
noodles off if you put the whole thing
in it's not going to fry correctly break
it apart take a handful of the dried
noodles before you start to fry you also
want to fry the noodles in batches so
that they all get evenly cooked if you
overcrowd the pan they're going to get
burnt so whenever you're frying you
really want to make sure it's the right
temperature so you get the right
consistency and that it cooks through we
tried find these noodles at different
temperatures
and
too low and nothing happens they just
become like oily noodles if it's too
high the noodles will get brown really
fast so you really want to use a
thermometer
[Music]
so the rice noodles are going to cook
really really fast as soon as they've
expanded you can use a slotted spoon to
remove them onto a sheet tray once you
fry the vermicelli noodles they just get
this incredible crunch which i
personally love so once your noodles are
fried you can move on to the chicken
gonna salt and pepper the
[Music]
chicken add it to a wall
[Music]
and at this point then you're going to
add that reserved teriyaki sauce this
takes a few minutes and the chicken is
going to get really
shellacked with this incredible sauce
it's going to be
deep and flavorful and it's i mean it's
truly such a good sauce you could just
kind of drink it if you wanted
i think the joy of this dish is that it
has a ton of flavor but that it's really
easy to do frying sure will take a few
minutes but honestly you could do this
for under an hour this could be a
weeknight meal that's more interesting
than take out and it's more interesting
than your usual chicken teriyaki
[Music]
once you're done with the chicken you
can serve it over the noodles
[Music]
i added some stuff like snap peas
radishes scallions but you can top it
with whatever you like
you can also just make the chicken on
your own you can make the rice noodles
on their own and put other toppings
something like shrimp or vegetarian
stir-fry it's a really versatile recipe
these noodles are worth making on their
own the chicken teriyaki is worth making
on its own but if you make it and use
other ingredients other toppings let us
know in the comments we want to see what
you're making at home
[Music]
you